pick the platform you're best at pick
the platform you have the momentum on
make content for only that platform if
you have the extra time and attention to
distribute it to other platforms don't
worry about being fancy and like right
for the platform just put it on there
anyways the thought of missed potential
was scarier to me than the thought of
failing okay well if you don't make a
change what does your life look like in
five years because that is frightening
if you are not where you want to be if
you are not any closer to where you want
to be and what changes between now and
six months from now if you don't make
the decision nothing except you're more
scared in six months because you've put
it off longer if you want to be
courageous fear has to be present it is
literally a prerequisite for courage
hey welcome to the think media podcast
my name is Heather Torres the host of
this show where we want to help you grow
your influence on YouTube and then turn
that influence into a high impact and a
high profit online business now today
we're jumping into part two of our
exclusive interview with Layla hermosi
Layla is an entrepreneur content creator
and just a Powerhouse woman bringing
some incredible content to YouTube and
sharing her journey of building her
businesses online it's been incredible
to be able to go through part one where
we talked about being a content creator
how she's creating her content team some
of the mistakes people make when they're
hiring and how a busy entrepreneur like
her is able to create so much great
content we talk about the starting the
struggle and so much more in episode one
so make sure you go back and watch that
today in this episode we're going to be
jumping into the mindsets going to a
million what does it take to get to a
million dollars what does it take to
even get to your first one hundred
thousand dollars and what are some some
of the things that you have to overcome
as an entrepreneur in this space to be
able to hit your goals all of that is
happening in today's episode so lean in
and let's get started oh wait before we
go there I want to let you know that
today's episode is brought to you by
21videotips.com you can go there if you
want to learn the video secrets of the
most successful entrepreneurs right now
who are killing it on YouTube and social
media go there to 21videotips.com get
the free downloaded resource and get
your free Master Class alright now let's
jump into today's episode
we I want to Pivot the conversation a
little bit because you just mentioned
team yeah and I think that's something
that you do really great at is building
teams
um around you to support you in whatever
business and especially in this content
business so what did it look like
um when you first got started you you
just popped open the camera or you know
popped open the laptop made a couple
videos but how did you then go about
creating your first hire in the space of
your content creation yeah
um basically it came about because I
started making content it was gaining
traction
um you know Alex had been making content
he had some vendors that he was working
with and so I started working with those
vendors me being the like managerial
very high expectations person that I am
was like this is not enough like I need
more help I need more assistance like
this is me doing a lot of work to create
the content like I would like a team
that can help me create the content it
can be our content that we're making
like I don't need to just because I'm
the face of Layla's brand doesn't mean
Layla is the only one who creates the
brand and so as soon as I realized I was
like okay I start studying like Gary and
Patrick Davis some other people like big
content teams and I was like oh my gosh
if I can build a team I can make content
yeah duh like I don't need to do this on
my own like I should hire people who
know how to do this not just the
technicalities of editing a video but
who understand brand and who understand
like what I need to be putting out there
because there's a lot of things I don't
know
um and so I think that a lot of people
over complicate it because they think
that they need to know more than they do
but it's like any other thing like if
you're in business and you're watching
this video I would be like if you know
how to hire like you don't go learn how
to build like to develop to to code when
you want to build software you hire a
lead coder he builds the code team and
then you have a product that's coded
right and so I looked at it the same way
which is
looking at what kind of person would we
need that we could be around all the
time that had the expertise what kind of
experience would they need
um and then what would we need them to
do and were they equipped to do that and
you know we were lucky to find that
person and I think what a lot of people
do wrong Heather is they start from the
bottom up and I think that's where a lot
of people go wrong with teams they try
to cheap out and they say I'm going to
hire all the video editors and then the
person that's like you know a grand a
month to edit this and I'm gonna just
build this team and I see a lot of my
friends who are very big content
creators bigger followings than me who
are like Layla how are you doing this
like it's such a mess I'm just everyday
inundated with the content and I'm like
oh I have no idea how the systems work I
hired the one person who was the right
person for the role and He is building
the team and that is what you should do
because if you build the the lower level
teams for the content then they all are
going to still come to you anyways it's
built the wrong way and then that person
never has true autonomy over the
department so it's just like in business
how you want to pick the leader and then
allow the leader to build it their way
and those people are loyal to them not
to you that's how I'm doing it with the
content so so smart so you um what are
some things uh one of my questions is if
someone is actually looking for that
person right they're like who's the
person and we get this a lot people say
like I need a Heather or I need a I need
an Omar and we know what that means but
what are some of the you know skills
that you actually look for and you've
hired so many different people so how
did you narrow it down to like this is
what I need yeah I think I thought about
you know who what are the kind of
personalities that I've worked with in
the past that I do I mesh really well
with like we get along really well
because someone that you're going to be
talking about your your personal brand
with is someone that you have to in my
opinion get along personally really well
with because they're one of the I mean I
spend the most time with Caleb out of
anyone on the team and so I was like I
have to personality wise have a match
they also have to have a match for the
company in terms of can I provide them
with experiences that they're looking
for in their career so I'm like yeah
okay if I can find someone who's been on
teams that have built Brands before but
they want to be the one who builds Our
Brands then that's the kind of person
I'm looking for right someone who sees
this opportunity that they can be behind
you know Alex and Layla hermosi building
the brand right
um and then the piece in terms of skill
set I determine on the interviews which
is if it's something I don't know a lot
about which when you know we hired Caleb
like I didn't I don't I still feel like
I don't know anything about content
um I basically was like I want to be
sold on the fact that this person knows
more than me and what they're telling me
aligns with all the experts I've talked
to right because I have tons of friends
with huge followings right and they're
more content creators than they are
business people and so I ask them and
interview them essentially and say like
what are you looking what do you think
about content how do you think of
strategy how do you think all these
things and I gather like the common
themes of like what they're saying and
I'm like okay here's the five things
that I'm gonna look for in terms of what
somebody's saying and then I just look
in the interview is this person's
reflecting those things and it's like
you can tell right off the bat when you
know what you're looking for and so do
they have the personality match do they
have the skill set match do they have
the culture match
and I think for each person
it's going to be a little bit different
for Content because are you entertaining
or are you educating right that's
another big thing like Caleb for example
came from someone that was educating but
also somewhat entertaining right but
mostly educating right versus somebody
that might have come from a huge content
creator that's purely entertainment you
know they're jumping off a building and
they're doing this they're more Mr B
style yeah that's not going to be and I
actually even with vendors have had that
not be a match because the vendor is
trying to get me to jump off a freaking
building or you know give a hundred
thousand dollars away on the street I'm
like what you know like I am too busy to
give 100 like I'll donate on online like
so I think it's understanding all those
things about what you look for in the
person what you look for on the skill
set and then understanding have they
made similar kind of content like that
in the past you know somebody who worked
for an e-commerce business and built an
e-commerce brand but didn't build a
personal brand probably not going to be
the best to build your brand right so I
think it's looking for that really
relevant experience otherwise you have
to fill in the gaps yeah and a lot of
entrepreneurs will get themselves kind
of in a jam they will be the ones you
doing all the content right they'll be
like I'm gonna figure out the editing
I'm gonna figure out those pieces and if
there's one thing I want to teach people
it's I don't do any of this either like
finally I mean I do it when I'm at home
I I've got it set up where I can press
record I know how to do that makes it
easy but in all the other things you
know we've gone to a level where we can
bring someone in what do you say for
someone who maybe isn't at that level
yet but they're they're getting a
business off the ground and they want to
be making content what's the advice for
that entrepreneur I would say that you
should make the one pick the platform
you're best at pick the platform you
have the momentum on make content for
only that platform and then if you have
the extra time and attention to
distribute it to other platforms don't
worry about being fancy and like you
know making it right for the platform
just put it on there anyways
um because that's kind of what we did in
the beginning when we were just like
being Scrappy is like okay I'm best at
this platform that platform will be the
only kind of content I make and I will
just throw on the rest of the platforms
even if it doesn't look great yeah
um because it's better to get it out
there and start gaining traction and
attention than to not put anything out
at all yeah when it comes to building
teams um you have decided that you want
people to be in person or just to be
around you what's the benefit of that
versus a lot of people will just be fine
with people being in other countries and
all that kind of what's your philosophy
around building an in-person team yeah
and I'll say the in-person team is
actually just our media team great so
that's what we're building it is an
in-person media office
um I think that there are certain kind
of work there's certain kind of work
that is better done in person and when
you're building someone's personal brand
the outcome that you want is it to be on
brand and so how do you know if it's on
brand if you spend no time with that
person and so I think that the reason
that a media team that's building a
personal brand not a product brand is
better to be in person is because the
more that they know us the better they
can do their job and so the more time
they spend with myself and Alex the
better those videos are going to be the
better the Twitter is going to be like
because they're going to get that
discretionary time with us yeah and
they're going to hear all these little
ancillary things we say on the side and
they're just going to know us that much
better it's like the best way to do
product marketing is to get to know the
product to become a consumer of the
product it's kind of same with brand
think of yourself as the product it's
like how do you consume it well you
spend time with the person and so for a
media team I think it makes a lot of
sense I also think that it helps with
workflows and things like that like
creative brainstorming to be in person
too sure
um the one thing I'll say is that I
would never require people to be in the
office a certain amount of days like I
have dedicated ourselves we've dedicated
to getting an office with the
expectation that I don't care how many
days people are in there I care that we
we also want to use the office we will
use it when we need to use it and I
believe that if it is there and it has
the things that people need people will
want to be in it more than not so good
so good I want to Pivot and talk about
building a business and um I love that
you guys are talking about building from
that one million to 3 million I pulled
up a stat and it said new small business
owners with less than five years
experience earn 49 000 on average that's
including their bonus and tips and all
those things small business owners from
five to ten earning about seventy
thousand so I love when you're talking
about getting to the million and I want
to talk about that uh here but what
about that first 100 000 what was that
like building to your first 100 000.
awful yeah yeah
um the the reason is is just because you
know I say like getting from
um basically the first level which is
like going from you know entrepreneur to
like a producer uh per se is you the
problem is that you have no idea what
you're doing and so the thing is is that
you're trying all these things and you
have no experience to drawn you have
education but there's no experience to
match with that education so you're not
sure if the things you're doing makes
sense or not so I think it's just you're
in this world of feeling very lost and
that's why it's so hard
um when we were first building gym
launch uh to its first 100 000 you know
it's
you know you take advice from somebody
you try the advice it doesn't work do I
not work or does the advice not work
like you're just constantly questioning
things the thing is is that everyone
wants to hear like how can you make that
you just have to be okay with it yeah
you know and I think that you have to
almost have that like Blind Faith for
that first period to just know that if
you keep testing and trying you will
find something that works there's no
magic bullet there's no magic pill and
you shouldn't just blindly listen to
someone on how to do it yeah you talked
about uh in that first one million
um that idea of overthinking so just
always being in that constant
overthinking and when I saw that I was
like I relate to that so much because
you're reading the book you're watching
the thing you're going to the courses
you're trying to figure this out because
inside you know that you are capable of
it but you just can't get it out talk
about what that was like for you and
that overthinking phase yeah it was
depressing you know I think actually I
think you have more anxiety when you're
overthinking the irony of it is that
you're overthinking trying to avoid
taking action that will make you anxious
but in doing that you actually promote
more anxiety because you're teaching
your brain that taking a leap taking a
chance is a dangerous thing and so the
longer you avoid starting the more you
feel anxious and then eventually you
feel more anxious sitting than you do
actually taking action which is the
funny part of it all like I think I felt
almost relieved when I took action and
then actually elated the day after so
when I was in that phase I mean it was
constantly consuming courses watching
YouTube watch it it's funny because
someone asked me recently if you watch
YouTube I was like I and I just got back
into watching more I haven't in so long
because I over consumed for so much of
my time that I could have just been
doing yeah you know what I mean so I
think it's constantly consuming things
idle ideating you need biodomain you
never do anything with the domain you
start something you do a project you
never launch the project like and it's
constantly just because your brain's
tricking you I think a lot of times what
people don't realize is that you have to
work against your Natural Instincts to
start a business because your brain is
going to constantly tell you it's going
to have automatic I say ants you know
yeah they use it in Psychology automatic
negative thoughts uh so you've got these
ants in your brain they're like you're
gonna fail you're gonna die like it's
gonna all go down you're gonna lose all
your money and you believe them because
you have no evidence to the contrary and
so the reason it's so hard is because
you have to actively take a stance
against your brain and say I don't
believe you and I'm going to do it
anyways or even if these things happen
I'll be okay and so you have to take an
absolute contrarian stance to the
thoughts that are coming up in your
brain in order to get yourself to take
action so that you can finally generate
some evidence to why you could be
successful in the future yeah yeah and
how I when you're saying that I have so
many memories of being in those phases I
remember the first time we launched
video ranking Academy we had the URL
spelled wrong we didn't give the right
call to action the webinar was way too
long but we celebrated after because we
actually did the thing like we actually
did it and from that to now it's
incredible to say like what if we never
did it and and I think so many times if
people write this down what would you do
if fear wasn't an option like what like
what if what if it all worked out what
if it was possible instead of always
going to that negative it's not possible
um as someone's going into that million
that next phase is really
um where they've got you you said it
that people get stuck because of three
things people in their life they have a
well-paying job or even the fear of
making that next step out of that job
talk about that phase
um for you because even when you came
into doing gym launch with Alex you like
quit everything and went all in talk
about those pieces for someone trying to
get to that first million yeah you know
I think that
it the tough part about it like for me
um I had stuff that was going well right
but what I think that you have to do is
you have to one recognize that the
things that are working for you now
aren't always going to work for you and
so like if I were to continue to do
these things and have my life this way
what does my life look like in five
years if I don't make a change
okay well what was my life look like if
I do make a change and for me like the
thought of continuing to bounce back and
forth and like ideate on what should I
do what should I not do okay I'll just
keep training online and in person and
working these like very long days where
I know I'm not fulfilled and I know I
could do more with my life the thought
of missed potential was scarier to me
than the thought of failing and so I
think that people would do themselves a
favor if they extrapolate it out okay
well if you don't make a change what
does your life look like in five years
because that is frightening if you are
not where you want to be if you are not
any closer to where you want to be and
what changes between now and six months
from now if you don't make the decision
nothing except you're more scared in six
months because you've put it off longer
and so I think that you have to if
people can understand that the longer
you wait the more fearful and anxious
you will be that is how the human brain
works then they can get themselves to
hopefully take action sooner and I think
one thing that I realized in that phase
was
courage is not present without fear and
so if you want to be courageous fear has
to be present it is literally a
prerequisite for courage and so at that
phase that is what you have to have so
you have to have courage which is to be
able to take action in spite of fear
while fear is present people think I
have to get rid of this fear I have to
not be so scared in order to do these
things not true at all in fact not at
all what you do is you get used to being
scared people are like oh I'm so jealous
you're so good at speaking like I get so
nervous I was like I'm just good at
being nervous like it's not that I'm not
nervous I'm better at being nervous than
you I can be nervous and deliver a cake
speech and they're like
you know and so I think that what you
have to understand that phase in front
of anyone who's watching is like the
feelings are never if your goal is to
eliminate a human feeling you're yeah
you know like you're not gonna eliminate
fear anxiety this has been there for
millions of years you're not gonna you
know you're not the one who's gonna
figure it out yeah and so I think that
you have to learn at that phase to act
despite those feelings and that's the
thing that got me going is I was like
this is not real this fear is made up in
my head it is an evolutionary thing like
the more I educated myself on how the
brain worked the more I understood how I
could get myself to take action
I could motivate myself enough with the
evidence that my brain is actually not
telling me the truth all the time the
thoughts I have that are catastrophizing
my terrible business and all the things
I'm going to lose are actually maybe not
real yeah and that was what allowed me
to take action to get over that hump and
to really just paint that picture of
what's my life gonna look like in five
years I use that a lot in terms of
decision making because I want to make
sure I'm always driving forward and I'm
setting my future self up for success
rather than keeping my present
self-comfortable yeah and so many so
many good nuggets in that that was so
good I want to touch more on where you
said you are studying more about the
mind and one thing I've noticed and I
think all entrepreneurs whether you're
just getting started as a content
creator or an entrepreneur you're just
starting your business or whether you
are Leila hermosi who's sold a business
and building another one that the
struggle never seems to really go away
right like as you keep going it's it's
not like you're gonna escape the
struggle it's how you deal with it and I
I want you to go deeper on that because
those have been really impactful to me
um in how you've been sharing that on
online yeah I'll tell you this which is
my good friend uh Dr Trevor Kashi he
said uh Layla there's one thing I want
you to hit on in your content to tell
the people is that uh you can feel one
way and act another tell them that you
feel like them and tell them that you
act differently than them and so I think
that is the only difference people
assume they see you know people like Ed
mylett and garyvee and all these people
on stage and they're like oh they must
not feel how I feel
they do feel how you feel they're human
right but one that you can interpret
emotions differently right and two is
that you can understand that those
emotions will always be present you can
change how you behave though so I can be
terrified I can still speak on stage and
so I think that what I've realized is
that
um over time and especially like I'll
tell you like you assume that when you
make a certain amount of money for some
reason we correlate this like certain
feelings will go away you'll feel less
anxious you'll feel less stressed you'll
feel more successful and I when I got to
the amount of money that I never thought
I would have at a young age I was very
sad because I realized I was more
anxious more scared more stressed now
that I have the money because I had it
to lose right right and so that was when
I started really getting back into
researching more because I researched a
lot when I was helping people lose
weight back in the day when I was a
personal trainer in terms of the
psychology and what prevents people from
losing weight and it's such similar
things which is
assuming certain feelings will go away
and so I think that what I've just
realized is
you cannot let me put it this way I
don't negotiate with my anxiety I don't
negotiate with my fear I'm not saying a
lot of times I think what people do is
they try to negotiate with it you're
anxious about starting a business so you
say well I'll just do X Y and Z I'm not
going to negotiate with my anxiety I'm
going to say f you you'll be there and
I'll do it anyways I can be good at
being anxious
and so it's almost like if I negotiate
with it it's like we're in the same
conversation kind of like with the
trolls on YouTube I don't need to
anxiety is a fake thing that my brain
has made up and it doesn't need to be
here anymore right it's not it's not
serving me in the present day of like
our society it's like why am I talking
to it why am I accommodating it why am I
doing things around it and so instead I
just say not entering the conversation
with you you can be there you can rile
me up my heart can race I can sweat and
I will do it anyways and so that's what
I've realized and I think been my
biggest
um
like Advantage I guess you could say is
that I just believe like anytime I'm
scared or something and I'm like
I just tell myself I'm willing to be
scared I'm willing to be anxious I'm
willing to be stressed I am actually
good at it and so I think that if more
people could take that approach rather
than trying to eliminate something that
you're never going to eliminate then I
think people would be a lot happier
because if you just remember you're like
wait I'm not gonna die from feeling
anxious like who's the last person died
from feeling ancient you know what I
mean like I'll be okay yeah I can do it
yeah so so good
um I I want to leave with just a couple
tips or advice that you would give to
um someone who's really you know they
really want to get started they really
want to get started and they see that
zero to a million and they're sitting at
that zero and they're like the mountain
is in front of them what what advice do
you have to that girl that's like I want
to do it but I'm just scared you have to
befriend fear
it's not stopping you if it's your
friend but like when it's your enemy and
you're opposing it then you're
constantly fighting it you don't need to
fight with fear you just need to
befriend fear and so it's like cool
little friend fear this is so lame but
like my little friend right here he's
gonna come on the journey with me yeah
and we're gonna go start this business
together people like what I'm like yeah
I have a friend and she always jokes she
goes oh anxiety I just keep it in my
purse all day she's like it's with me
right now I can feel it and I'm like one
she's again sometimes he likes to pop
out and say hey and sometimes he goes
back into my purse but he's always there
and so I think that it's understand that
you have to befriend those negative
feelings expect them and then walk
yourself through once you get started
and the negative feeling comes up how
are you going to handle it because that
is always what I do when the worst
feeling comes up when you feel
absolutely terrible when you feel
terrified how are you going to respond
play that out in your head ahead of time
when the moment comes you will naturally
feel less of that emotion because you
have already prepared paired in terms of
what am I going to do and the Brain
likes predictability yeah so the best
thing I'll say is like already decide
how are you going to befriend the fear
how are you going to act when it's there
what's the conversation you're going to
have and then just play it out and don't
let that stop you because that's the
excuse everyone uses yeah nobody feels
any different than than the person if
you're watching this and you haven't
gotten started yet like nobody feels any
different than you we all feel terrified
we all feel terrible it's okay
join the club join the club I'll be
human yes I love it uh what are you
excited about what are you working on
what are some projects that are in the
pipeline
um what's new for Layla yeah um honestly
I'm just really excited about building
the team right now because going from a
team of almost 100 people to uh like
three is tough so you know I'm like can
someone do that oh me yeah it's me that
does that now
um so I'm really excited because we have
pretty much got our uh executive and
leadership team in place and now we're
hiring uh and really like expanding the
team to to get those levels underneath
built and that is exciting for me
because I
I'm really excited to build this
business in which
um we can make a huge impact on people
um like I always wished like this is
kind of just the business I always
wanted right where it's like I wish I
could go to someone and they could have
like an expert for every function of my
business who could look at it and tear
it apart and rebuild it and like help
hire the people and like do all that and
that's what we're building and it's
almost there now which is really cool
um I just get really you know Alex told
me the other day he was like I was
running the the weekly meeting and he
was like oh my God he's like you're so
excited afterwards I was like why and
he's like you're like meetings
communication cages more people yes
Layla loves this and I do I love it I
love having a big team I love creating a
place where people love to work that is
what I love and I think that Alex has
more of the external vision of what
we're going to do for the companies I
have more of the internal positions like
I just love creating a place where I can
create an environment in which somebody
can fulfill their dreams like that is
just the coolest thing to me and so I'm
just excited to do that more because the
more more people we have on the team the
more momentum I feel from it's like the
energy almost and the more I'm excited
to do team trainings and Leadership
Retreats and all those things because
that's just what I that's like my jam so
fun well I want to say thank you for
coming on the podcast thank you for
stepping out in the fear and just
starting to create content because
there's women like me who need to see
that example ahead of them and I'm just
so honored that you just put it out
there that you just go for it and you
start making the fun things where I'm
like I'm geeking out the same way this
is so cool I felt like I was so
different and like I'm not there's
someone like me so I just want to honor
you and say please do more of it there's
more women that need what you have
there's more men that need which you
have there's more businesses that can be
impacted by the work that you and Alex
do and I think that's really what's
going to change our world is the
businesses that really see how to do it
the right way so thank you for stepping
out and doing the content I appreciate
that thank you so much thanks for coming
on the show yeah we did it yeah yay
well I hope that you enjoyed that
session with Layla hermosi so many
takeaways and if you're watching over on
YouTube let me know what your aha moment
was from this episode and if you are
listening on the podcast you can rate or
review this show over on Apple podcast
let me know what your takeaway was I
cannot wait to read it and if you've not
yet gone to
21videotips.com that's where you should
go next after listening to today's
episode you're going to want to get this
free download and free masterclass
sharing all of the best video secrets of
the most successful entrepreneurs right
now they are giving away the juicy
things that you're not gonna hear
anywhere else so make sure to go there
and get your free resource thank you so
much for listening we cannot wait to
bring you more episodes just like this
with entrepreneurs just like Layla
hermosi we'll catch it in the next
episode bye fam
foreign